[موسيقى]
عاشت طفوله النابضه فلم ترضى بان تضع
نفسها في زاويه واحده بل تعددت مواهبها
وتنقلت بين الموسيقى والرياضه وظهرت على
خشبه المسرح ثم كتبت والفت اغنياتها لتحدث
ضجه لا سابق لها في الساحه الفنيه هذه
الضجه المستمره حتى يومنا هذا بطلتها نجمه
البوب الامريكيه تايلور سويفت فما قصتها
ولدت تايلور اليسون سويفت بولايه
بنسلفانيا عام
وتميزت اثناء الطفولتها بممارسه العديد من
الانشطه اللامنهجيه كركوب الخيل وتعلم
الموسيقى حيث تلقت دروسا في الصوت
والتمثيل فقامت باداء موسيقى الكانتري في
المعارض والمهرجانات الموسيقيه المحليه
والاحداث الرياضيه والمقاهي كما فازت
بمسابقه شعر وطنيه
عندما كانت في التاسعه من عمرها فقط
عندما اصبحت في سن الحاديه عشره بدات
والدتها تساعدها بالبحث عن شركه تسجيلات
لتبني موهبتها لكن جميع الابواب التي
طرقتها كانت قد اغلقت في وجهها لم تياس بل
بدات تكتب الاغاني بنفسها وقادها ذلك
لمحاوله كتابه اغنيتها الاولى
ثم حصلت على اول فرصه احترافيه عندما
انتقلت من ولايه بنسلفانيا الى ناشفيل حيث
ابرمت عقدا مع شركه تسجيلات ار سي اي كما
وقعت معه سوني اي تي في بصفتها مؤلفه
اغاني وكانت في الرابعه عشره فقط
في عام 2005 انضمت الى شركه تسجيلات بيج
ماشين من اجل انشاء البومها الخاص وفي
غضون عام واحد كانت جاهزه للبومها الاول
حيث كتبت ثلاث اغنيات بمفردها وشاركت في
كتابه الاغاني المتبقيه باع الالبوم الذي
حمل اسم تايلور سويفت اكثر من
38,500 نسخه في الاسبوع الاول واكثر من
خمسه ملايين نسخه في مبيعاته العالميه
فواصلت تايلور مسيرتها بثقه واطلقت
البومها الثاني فيرلس في عام 2008 ليبيع
اكثر من 500 وتسعين الف نسخه في اسبوعه
الاول وما يقرب من ثمانيه ملايين وخمسمائه
الف نسخه حول العالم وهو ما كان انجازا
كبيرا بالنسبه لفتاه ريفيه تبلغ من العمر
18 عاما
سرعان ما انتشرت شهرتها خارج الولايات
المتحده واوروبا ثم بدات تحصد الجائزه تلو
الاخرى كما واصلت منذ عام 2010 باربع
جوائز غرامي بما في ذلك افضل البوم للعام
لتصبح اصغر شخص يفوز بهذا التكريم على
الاطلاق ثم في وقت لاحق من العام نفسه
ظهرت تايلور في فيلم الكوميديا الرومانسيه
فالنتاينز داي قبل ان تطلق البوم سبيك ناو
الذي نالت عنه جائزه
وفي العام التالي فازت بجائزه جرامي لافضل
اداء منفرد في البلد وافضل اغنيه ريفيه عن
اغنيه مين التي هي ايضا جزء من البوم سبيك
ناو وصلت تايلور نجاحاتها مع كل البوم
جديد تطرحه للاسواق وكان من اهمها
كما اعادت تسجيل البومات قديمه لها لتعيد
احيائها من جديد خلال العامين السابقين
خلال مسيرتها التي امتدت لاكثر من 15 عاما
نجحت تايلور في حصد الكثير من الجوائز
ولعده مرات كان من اهمها
لكنها وفي عام 2022 وضعت بصمه كبيره في
التاريخ الموسيقي الامريكي مع البومها حيث
استحوذت اغانيها على جميع المراكز في
قائمه افضل عشر اغاني فرديه في الولايات
المتحده وهو الانجاز الذي لم يتحقق لفنان
امريكي منذ 64 عاما
على الصعيد المادي كسبت الفنانه التي لم
تتم 34 عاما 92 مليون دولار في عام 2022
كما تتربع الفتاه الريفيه اليوم على ثروه
تقدر بخمسمائه وسبعين مليون دولار
[موسيقى]